[Music]
when Kacey Musgraves says ye Selena
Gomez says ha get it
yee-ha yeah check out Selena singing and
dancing her little heart out at Casey's
show in Los Angeles on Sunday so was
clearly having the time of her life with
her gal pals
[Music]
and when it came time for Casey to
perform a cover of I Will Survive Selena
went all out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm obsessed for that video but it gets
even better after the show Selena went
backstage to hang with Casey for a bit
her whole group of friends posed for a
pic with a country singer - eg had an
eyewitness inside the concert who says
Selena was seen only drinking iced tea
and a bottled water though her pals were
sharing cocktails Selena's musical night
out comes as she's gearing up to release
a new music of her own I cannot wait
everything's good I'm super super happy
yes I'm just nervous about it because I
feel like the next few choices that I'm
gonna make are very crucial so I'm
trying to be really really diligent and
just patient a source previously told
et's she's planning to release it later
this year and that it'll be super
personal quote Selena has gone through a
lot over the years and is ready to share
it with the world
one of Selena's BFFs and frequent
collaborators Julia Michaels told me
that Selena is writing her new music
herself she keeps teasing new music
we're dying to know if you guys are
working together again I'm not she's
amazing I think she wants to do her own
thing
and have her own words and her own
expressions and and I think that's
amazing I want her to flourish yeah she
deserves it she cannot wait for her new
music also loving how happy she looks
these days what do you guys think the
new music will sound like though let me
know on Twitter or in the comments and
for all the latest on Selena keep it
locked to all things et until next time
I'm Katie Krauss and bye for now
[Music]